Alam allayikum. My name is Mahi Ahmedi.
I'm a researcher in history, political
science and I'm currently studying in
computer science. My question is is
pretending to jadu or or magic or by by
whatever name you would like to address
it. I won't go into specifics but the
certain family member recently found a
piece of paper in which was supposedly
some uh elements of negativity which
they felt was of of this nature and uh
they themselves uh indulged in similar
practices to um to obtain a um a remedy
for it believing that you know this is
wrong. I was wondering if you could um
shed some light on this matter. There's
a question that what do I have to say
about black magic and what's the remedy?
As far as black magic is concerned,
there is something like black magic. The
Quran mentions that in surah falak
mentioned in surah bakar. There is black
magic. It does exist. But we should not
involve in black magic. We should not do
it. We should have faith in Allah
subhanana wa tala. And as far as the
remedy is concerned, the last two surah
the moatain surah falak and surah nas
were revealed for this. These two suras
are the remedy for black magic. Now see
one thing is that that normally whenever
people think that something has
possessed first thing is Allah says ask
the person who has knowledge. Surah
16:43 sur
go to a doctor. If the doctor doesn't
tell you the treatment or cannot treat
the disease go to a psychiatrist. Most
of the people who claim to have black
magic they can be cured by doctors and
psychiatrists. There can be
possibilities that actually a jin may
have come and black magic may have taken
place. So at that case you can follow
the guidance of Quran and sunnah. You
can go to a person who's an expert in
this field. But I'm sorry to say most of
the people who are experts in this field
who claim more than 99% are fake. More
than 99% according to me it is my
analysis more than 99% who claim that
they can cure black magic. They are
frauds. The moment you realize he's
asking from you money, that means he's
trying to make a fast buck. Do this, do
that, give me so much money, £1,000,
£2,000. He's trying to make a fast buck
out of it. So there are people who are
experts in this field. I know a couple
of them in Saudi Arabia, mashallah,
they're very knowledgeable. I don't know
of anyone else otherwise.
So if he's knowledgeable, we should
realize that if he gives the treatment
from Quran and Suna, so we have to go to
a specialist who specialize in the
field. Hope that answers the question.